there's no doubt the concentration of
Dementors in and around aaban was unlike
anything The Wizarding World had ever
encountered before it all begins with an
incredibly powerful sorcerer by the name
of AC Christus who once called aaban his
home in these times it wasn't a prison
it was something much worse thanks to
his numerous concealment charms the
island in the North Sea didn't appear on
any map here he practiced the worst
kinds of dark magic setting aaban up as
a death trap for Wayward muggle Sailors
he would lure them to the island torture
them and eventually kill them aisus was
never caught or punished for his crimes
upon discovering the island Wizards were
left with a complex problem and no easy
solutions unsurprisingly there were many
who argued for what may seem like the
most logical response destroy the island
and everything in it and therein lies a
significant problem you see Dementors
cannot be killed